I went to look at
the oceanic diet
people that live off the ocean.
And for this
I ended up going to Borneo.
Borneo is split into
three countries
Brunei, Indonesia, Malaysia.
I went to the Malaysian part.
This part here in
Bodgaya Island.
So, I went and
met with the Bajau.
About one million Bajau
split over all these
countries I mentioned.
And they really live off
what they find in the ocean.
Bit of refreshment to
get you in the mood .
This is Tarumpit, you know,
on his way to the office.
( audience laughter )
And, so they live on
stilt houses mostly.
And it's quite an
incredible experience
walking into one
of these house.
There's the lapping, you
know, sound of the water.
People sometime fish straight
through the planks like this.
There's water
right below .
But the real hardcore Bajau.
They are called the "Bajau
laut", from the ocean.
They live in boats,
handmade boats called lepa.
Lepa-lepa or lepa.
And this is their life. This
is where they give birth,
this is where they cook,
this is where they
do everything.
This is it.
They live inside there,
they sleep in there,
they spend all their
life in this.
Moving around, yeah,
semi-nomadic, kind of.
They go around
islands finding spot
where they hunt, they
fish, they gather food.
And they cook in the back of
the boat in this metal thing.
Fire straight on the boat,
I wouldn't do that.
But you know, it works.
They sometime cut
out seaweed in small pieces
boil it in salty
water and eat it.
There is a lot of
collagen in it.
It's really good for
skin apparently.
And then when the tide gets
low in the full moon period
they go and gather
seashells etcetera.
They even find these
little guys here.
Urchins. They collect
a lot of urchins .
And eat the roe inside.
I love these kind of stories,
of this kind of destination
nothing can be pre-arranged.
There's no way to reach
out to these people,
you just have to be lucky.
And so you are on the
lookout all the time for stuff.
And so I am going around
in the boat in the morning
and we see this guy.
Let me show you
what he is doing.
With his hand he is going
forward like this.
He's got one foot out
with just one fin.
And he's scanning the bottom
of the ocean looking for food.
And then soon enough
he got an octopus.
And then you know, later
on, he got stingrays and
a lot of effort is
put into that again
four-five-six
hours at sea
trying to get some
food to bring back.
There's a connection
between the body
and the food that feeds
it and fed the body.
And here again
you see that.
You see the octopus
is clinging onto him
and he's got that close
to him like that.
I was trying this was ...
one thing I kept in
mind on that story.
To really get that connection,
that intimacy with food.
Food is something you eat
that gets in your body
that makes you live, I
mean it's just incredibly
powerful thing when
you think about it.
So, I meet with
the brother from
the guy that was
hunting with...
Put on his skinny jeans and
he's just so at ease in there.
- ( audience laughter )
- It's just amazing.
And he got this little fish,
this little bat fish there.
( speaking in Malay )